[Music]
in lifesavers news live servoz rebel a
commercial yeah I'm on with the white in
the strawberry oh yeah those extra
popular I don't have anymore huh looks
luscious what was the name of it though
they had a specific name for that was a
creamy testicle where that sounds like a
porno was a green favor screensavers
flavor that's a great name yeah cream
face hey submitted by Mu Shu
mu Muslims awake for Ramadan are being
praised among a group of heroes who
saved lives during a tragic residential
fire well we were awake enough to help
them out and I saw the video black so
sad so have you guys heard of the fire
that destroyed a 24 storey tower in
London no I'm sorry
it was live-streaming everywhere yeah it
was yeah everywhere so was it like a
terrorist attack so they stole my
knowledge they still haven't concluded
on what caused the fire
people were tryna dry already dry
clothes and all the stops caught on fire
the possibility but that's what always
happens no one said I heard and I don't
know if these are true yet but someone
said it might have been like a
refrigerator thing oh it's an electrical
problem and I also this is what I'm
reading from common since I don't know
what I'm saying is true but somebody
said that that building of the
predominantly like Muslim building I'm
not saying that that means that it isn't
a terrorist attack but like people were
just commenting on that there might be
some foul play to the tower uh
residential tower so they have about 120
apartments holding about 400-500 people
entire tower so this fire started around
1:00 a.m. and they're saying that it
started near the fourth floor and that
there were a lot of Muslims that are
awake at that time because of Ramadan
they had to they were about to eat and
so they were the first ones that notice
that this fire was happening and so
they're saying that this building all
red
they had years of complaints about the
fire safety in this building so who was
the landlord scrooge mcduck pretty much
yeah is like a board that just didn't
care there apparently it was even one
member of that board that kept speaking
up for the resident saying like hey you
know there are a lot of issues in those
towers we got to look at and then she
almost got fired but they're just
matches like on every floor and then
there's just cotton like in all the
corners of the desirability Washington
forces gasoline yeah just magnifying
glasses everywhere the Sun only shines
in well what it was is that there was
only one entry point for the entire
tower you need any students not illegal
right so that's that's like straight-up
illegal is look yeah and so they're
saying that there were no sprinklers or
fire alarm oh [ __ ] I'll wash creating
fire hazard prequels they're poor
placement of boilers and unprotected gas
pipe what is this like the slums of UK
London slum apartment yes they have
recently done work on the building and
so they're saying that they were using
this cheap cladding to built and so I
guess cladding what it is it's this
thermal construction material and so
they were using it to like refurbish the
house up the whole tower and so they
there were residents complaining against
the material that they do saying that
it's flammable not flammable but that it
was really cute oh they're using
charcoal as a bathroom tiles is that the
light of life and well I guess the other
thing the other uses for this is to
improve building insulation and the
outer appearance but that the residents
are complaining that this is sort of
like fire hazard and so there was one
resident alone that made 19 complaints
to the board and nothing was done yeah
yeah they just kept brushing away all of
the complaints and so once you know this
whole fire there were 78 people that
were taken to six hospitals four remain
in the hospital
18 are in critical condition there have
been 12 deaths so far but they expect
that number to climb
that's not Oh so what's what's happening
to the committee are they going to jail
well right now there's an investigation
going
this seems like if you knowingly do this
to cut corners save money and all this
stuff and I think they should all go to
jail because it's just as bad as like
they lit the fire themselves
yeah it's negligent well they always
burn their ball sacks that's also a good
one just like a lighter God holy dude
that looks like a SimCity thing you know
when you you know the game SimCity yeah
and it gets in your building catches on
fire looks just like the same no a lot
of building looks nice on the exterior
so I read an article that was about a
mother who was running down from the top
story with her six children and when she
got to the ground floor she only had
four left oh my god she doesn't know
where the other two are yeah there's a
lot of stories like that are just so
surreal and there was a baby that was
thrown out of the main story and a
toddler thrown from the fist why they
saw a baby's out the window
one of them times one of them uh comes
oh oh they're firefighters underneath
yeah so they were oh I thought they were
just throwing babies out like you know
what we're gonna burn a death so [ __ ] it
let's take our chances no I mean that's
what happened during 911 if people
didn't want to burn a death so they were
just like [ __ ] it they just jumped out
that's exactly what they're comparing
this event to six nine eleven pretty
much and so there are 200 firefighters
that were called out there were 45 45
fire engines on the scene so [ __ ] sad
it is really sad but luckily I mean I
guess a lot of people survived though
because they got they were hey wake up
to the fire and everyone just ran out
yeah a lot of the residents are just
thinking the Muslims saying like you
they were the first ones to respond
because they were wait water like to
help and like assist everyone to try to
get them out like they're just saying
that's awesome as a quote from one of
the residents are saying if it wasn't
for all these young Muslim boys around
here helping us coming from mosques more
people would have been dead so what what
is Ramadan like you don't eat your
one-month fat every year and they're
saying that during the month of Ramadan
Muslims believe that Allah revealed the
first verses of the Quran and so you're
not supposed to have any food or drink
smoking or sex during the day and that
you're only allowed one meal after
sunset and one meal before sunrise so
that's for the entire month apartment
before sunset so then this happened
before sunrise yeah so it was in the
middle of the night at 1:00 a.m. oh so
they're probably like getting their
first meal in or something like that
didn't even get to eat and I was when I
was in Riverside there was this dude
that left I can't remember I think the
toaster strudel in our are are you know
that dining common area and then in like
caught on fire and so there's like smoke
coming out the whole thing and then
everyone's rushing out and then my
friend Adam was sleeping in his bunk and
then I went out to him Adam the [ __ ]
place on fire let's go and he rolled
over and he went oh you dead
sighs lesson Wow Wow
he waved me off well what do you want me
to do I told myself later huh well
happened we final deal with the ketosis
oodles okay
those are grateful that we have
sprinklers because that whole thing
could have been preventable
yeah and I'm like when I look at
sprinklers you kind of take it for
granted you're like oh they're just
they're just whatever but then if there
was a fire at least the sprinklers would
save a lot of lives around the building
you get all annoyed at fire detectors
like when you cook a little bit too
crazy but you know seriously I took mine
now
what yeah cuz they're loud did beat when
they run out of batteries yeah
oh no no is cuz I cook and then all the
smoke just goes bad and I'm like shut up
and I took it out awesome
cookware it has smoke no it's just our
range sucks and then I'm just like in
the zone
um this [ __ ] idiot though he he
decided to smoke a cigarette right next
to the elevator and bring it inside the
elevator and what ended up happening was
the elevator just shut down and the
whole entire building at like one
am just back bad been hurt so the whole
apartment came outside we had to take
the stairs and [ __ ] the door started
automatically closing like double doors
all this stuff we went downstairs our
dogs were freaking now all of our
neighbors like wow [ __ ] is going on so
we're on the street and I'm TJ in djs
djs yes what are the chinese like 1 a.m.
oh damn yes I knew it damn it it was
like loud as [ __ ] to like it was so low
I was like bad bad I was like dang dude
my ears [ __ ] going crazy right now
it was cool though that shows how dope
your apartment complexes though they
might be being seriously yeah yeah it
was so loud and actually what it woke me
up
I knew that 100% now the Chinese do
because I heard like at the Vermont when
it first opened up know sometimes people
smoking in the [ __ ] elevator the same
[ __ ] would happen because we just
[ __ ] smoke out of nowhere what did
claire says do not smoke but i think
this will get fine but the huge amount
yeah I don't know the firefighter
commander it's like a huge thing can
they just beat their ass baby I feel
like if I think I would I think if I
caught someone smoking like inside my
apartment I think I just start smacking
them yeah she get branded with the no
smoking sign
yeah that's not to do that are doing
that especially in your complex I want
the rich Chinese dudes their wheels they
just pay the fine line well with that I
don't care yeah I do have our wine well
smoke amiss look over there man
no free fingers like this oh my god
three fire alarms are so crazy fire are
scary man like I've been through two
fires in my face oh yeah oh yes burning
cars in a freaking garage man that thing
is once it get our smoke builds up dude
it gets scary as hell and the [ __ ]
heat to like I could be like all across
the room but you could just feel the
heat and it's it's just hit you in the
face and then the smoke is just so dense
and then um after everything cools down
there's so much dust like
that just covers everything it's pretty
crazy
Wow have you ever had any experiences um
nothing like that no but as a kid I used
to play with fire yeah I always bring
the house down so I wanted to light
candles everywhere but now or you know
you put a stick in the campfire and you
wave it around like a fairy yeah I've
ever played without one net and fire no
hairspray and fire or raise if you go
like this you Shane to go and then if
you get two of them you can go I'm just
uh Corot stirrer lon
Bobby burns could you imagine what it
was like having this do to the child I
kill myself I think I just like see my
kid outside my life is ever less
successfully in your house I know I
would just like sit there watch my kids
I please burn to death so I don't have
to do it like please I just want a new
kids I hope you guys enjoy this video
for more please subscribe to our Channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]